all these phone calls came in from our
friends and relatives from germany about
how this crisis was evolving almost
overnight turned into a pandemic how
does that lead you to wanting to become
one of four members of germany's corona
investigative committee how does that
happen this pcr test is incapable of
telling us anything about infections
it's about creating fear so that people
will not ask any questions but do as
they're told there was a paper that was
leaked called the panic paper is the
panic paper a public paper or is it
private paper that we cannot see the
things that are stated in there is make
children feel responsible for the
torture deaths of their parents and
grandparents if they don't adhere to all
these anti-corona regulations how come
more people haven't come together to
want to do something about this yet
because only now do people begin to
understand that this is not something
that's going to be over within a very
short period of time i just want to make
sure the right people are held
accountable so you know
you know in the end it's going to be the
governments who are going to be held
accountable that's great going up
against deutsche bank and volkswagen was
almost the training ground for you to go
up against this one we believe that the
facts are going to take us right there
to the people who are actually
responsible not just to the puppets the
marionettes but to the people who are
really pulling the strength
my guest today is dr reiner fulmich who
is currently in germany he's a
tri-lawyer licensed both in germany and
in the state of california and some of
the work he's worked on in the past uh
huge lawsuits against deutsche bank
volkswagen fraud and now he's one of the
former members of the germany coron
investigative committee so with that
being said dr reiner thank you so much
for being a guest on valuetainment
thank you very much for having me yes so
you know you work on these two cases
with deutsche bank and volks volkswagen
if you don't mind kind of talking about
that how did that lead to
from working in that industry to all of
a sudden you want to go out there and
pursue coronavirus committee i mean how
does they'll go about so if you don't
mind taking a moment sharing with us
what you did with the deutsche bank and
volkswagen and how that led you to what
you're doing right now
well um it was part coincidence and part
experience i'd say um
back in uh march
my wife and i were living in uh in
northern california we have a ranch
there
and we were staying there from early
february until
late may
then we moved back to germany um i was
hoping to be able to get back as soon as
possible but that was not possible and
that's why we took our dogs with us um
but
up until then i had had a lot of
experience as a trial lawyer going after
fraudulent corporations like vw and
deutsche bank deutsche bank in
particular i used to work for them by
the way in the early 1990s uh i worked
in japan and my yeah and my boss then
was uh someone who was later to become
ceo of deutsche bank but and deutsche
bank used to be one of the
best banks in the world um
with a
sterling reputation
however in the early 1990s in japan i
realized that things were changing that
deutsche bank was ready to do anything
for uh for a dollar and uh didn't really
care about the law anymore they felt
like they were above the law
and that's why i left um because that's
not what i had studied law for and i
left i went back to germany went back to
the university of guertingan where i
taught i was a professor for a while
simultaneously i was
having my i was building up my law
practice until eventually i just wasn't
able to do both things at the same time
anymore so i switched and uh my small
law firm with then 14 17 lawyers uh
decided to um go after deutsche bank for
their
um fraudulent loans for
um actually what do you call us this
this is what
eventually blew up in the united states
first in the united states just like the
vw scandal blew up in the united states
first but in germany nobody really cared
about it um because the government
believes that this is one of the
corporations that are so important for
the german economy that you can't really
go after them so even though it's not
spelt out in this way um many germans
and even some of the judges in germany
believe that they have to take special
precautions that they cannot apply the
rule of law to deutsche bank
um it was for predatory lending uh for
financing through a bunch hundreds and
hundreds thousands of agents going out
and going to people's going into
people's homes and
persuading them to buy a piece of real
estate so that they would create
additional income in terms of
rental income which would then be um
good for their
an additional pension plan so to speak
without telling them however that these
pieces of real property were vastly
overpriced like they sold them at two
times actually even in many cases three
times its fair market value
uh basically defrauding the people who
um
who they wanted to be their customers by
telling them all by giving giving them
all kinds of false statements
um i i don't want to go into the details
of this because there's too much legally
sure there were blatant lies blatant
lies uh very similar the
vw diesel fraud case they sold their
cars which were functioning cars of
course but which did not really
comply with especially the california
emission standards but they and they had
put in the so-called defeat device which
um was okay
on a test stand but once the car moved
out into the real world uh the emissions
were much much higher than they should
have been so two big cases of fraud and
i had i had gathered a lot of experience
in a courtroom with these cases that's
why i that's why i'm saying um i was
ready for this but i wouldn't have
wanted to take this case on it's just
that uh the corona case um but it's uh i
was used to this i was used to sort of
running against into a wall even in
court because parts of the judiciary had
been
well are not as independent as they
should be here in germany because uh
politics
try tries to exert
exert
quite a bit of influence on the
judiciary as well simply because of the
notion that germany is an
export-oriented country and this
deutsche bank is one of the
is still one of the largest banks in
germany and we need it and vw of course
is one of the cornerstones of the german
economy by producing as many cars as
possible and selling them all over the
world so they're sort of above the law
at least in germany but not in the
united states
so so by the way are you still with uh
friends with your old boss who uh ended
up becoming a ceo or no
no you're not friends and did he fire
you or no what happened with it were you
fired or you just left
no you know you have to you have to keep
in mind that i did not work for them as
an attorney i didn't do any legal work i
was there in charge of their um
business in in japan and uh there was
only one instance when they needed me as
a lawyer because i i'm trained uh as an
american as a as an anglo-american
lawyer as well so they needed a couple
of contracts to be written up by someone
who knows what they're doing and that
was me
and this instance uh convinced me that i
just couldn't stay with them any longer
because it involved another
big fraud this time no consumer was
defrauded but um the uh french um uh
bank supervisor authority was defrauded
i'm not gonna go into any details forgot
legal i i thought well i'm not really
harming anyone but this is not what i
wanted to be as a lawyer so i left i
mean it makes sense i mean i was going
to say you're the wrong person of fire
because if somebody fires you you're
going to come back come after them and
sue them and
that that makes for a good story but
okay so how do you go from deutsche bank
how do you go from volkswagen i mean
these are in germany these are behemoths
these are
gods you know this is like you going
after ford motor company in u.s this is
like you're going after bank of america
or you know chase you're not going after
anybody small and maybe even bigger
because germany is a smaller country in
the economy than us is but how does that
lead you to wanting to become one of
four members of germans
germany's corona investigative committee
how does that happen
okay well i what i just told you is the
experience that i have and the
frustration tolerance that i have
developed over the years by just not
giving up keep going you're gonna get
them in the end truth will prevail um
but now comes the um the uh
well accident more or less um my wife
and i were just sitting there on our
ranch playing with our dogs i was
running every day
trying to recharge my batteries and then
we got
all these phone calls came in from our
friends and relatives from germany about
how this crisis was evolving and how
what i thought was just the seasonal flu
almost overnight turned into a pandemic
and how people began to be
really concerned about this is really
dangerous this is deadly and one name
kept coming up professor druzden
he's uh the leader of uh he's the
chief virologist at a german well-known
german probably one of the largest
european hospitals called charite which
is in berlin
and it's a it's a university hospital
and it serves two universities at the
same time
now i had never heard of this guy before
but i knew that he was the one who was
promoting all of a sudden overnight he
had changed his mind before this he kept
telling everyone oh this is going to be
not so serious you're not
you don't have to worry most people
won't have any symptoms
it'll just go by just like the seasonal
flow and as though somebody had given
him a signal overnight he changed his
tune
to this is extremely dangerous we're
gonna have to do something and he had
kept advising our politicians and it
turns out through a whistleblower we
know now he was the only person that our
government consulted the only person now
this is a gross violent violation of the
roman principle of audiator at altera
pars which means you have to listen to
the other side
in particular when you make decisions as
far-reaching as as the ones that were
taken by the german government the
lockdown the suspension of all of our
constitutional rights for an indefinite
period of time you have to listen to the
other side and obviously there was
another side except nobody listened to
it because the mainstream media and
everybody else who had been brought into
line probably
we don't know who really is behind this
but some powerful people some corporate
interests are behind this definitely
because you just have to follow the
money and then you will realize
pharmaceutical industry is making lots
of money tech industries making lots of
money so their representatives are the
ones who are pushing this they're the
ones who are pulling the strings but the
people out in the open are professor
dresden
and then the uh leader of the german
equivalent of the american cdc which is
rki is what it's called his name is
wheeler he's a veterinarian
as the head of the german equivalent of
the cdc and then there's uh the third
person is uh mr tadras a philosopher
uh who runs the
world health organization
so um
i couldn't i didn't quite know what to
make of this so i called a good friend
of mine someone who knows a lot about
medicine and this this guy is the one
who uh who stepped in when 12 years ago
we had a very very similar situation
with the swine flu that's my friend dr
wolfgang woodark who back then was in a
position of political power because he
was a member of the german bundestag
which is like the congress and he was
also a member of the council of europe
so he had a lot of power and the only
reason why back then that attempt of a
massive lobby attack
uh kind of backfired but if there's
still movies from 12 years ago which i
uh looked at and i couldn't i just i
thought it was about today
the same the same people who
advance the theory of everybody's gonna
die
did it back then including professor
dresden including what's his name neil
ferguson of the imperial college of uh
of england um they all pushed this story
eventually of course as we all know now
unless we have forgotten about it that
was just the common flu no more serious
than the common flu and by the way
that's what this is the the who just
issued a statement which confirmed that
professor yoanita's position of stanford
university
uh is correct that the mortality or the
lethality of this virus whatever it is
is no worse than the common flu at point
one four percent so uh my friend uh
wolfgang vodak told me you have to look
at the other side check out yo anita's
at stanford university check out
professor levitt who is a
nobel prize winner they're all of the
same opinion plus then he advanced some
more names from germany german
professors merlin
bhakti etc etc i spoke with many of them
or i watched their videos and they all
came to the same conclusion whatever
we're dealing with this is no worse than
the common flu
so i decided um i'm just gonna wait and
sit and wait until it's over but my wife
kept telling me reiner we can't do this
we're gonna have to do something you're
a lawyer you know how to do this i said
no i'm the only one out here because i
can't see any other lawyer
so i asked again i asked wolfgang
woodack is there anybody else of the in
the legal community is there any other
lawyer who's doing something about her
and he told me about a woman by the name
of beia tabana who's well known here in
germany she's a specialist in medic
medical law
and uh the next thing i knew about her
is that she spoke up
and then she was arrested and put into a
mental institution so that was uh
kind of motivating right she was she was
she was put in mental institution yeah
psychiatric ward uh she came out after a
few days but um that was not that was
extremely discouraging wait this lady
beatribana who is known in germany was
put into
a mental institution yeah for mental
instability simply because she had a
different opinion
um but who has the power to make that
happen i mean who who called the shots
to say you're going to a mental
institution that's a very good question
it's the executive we have we just like
in the united states of course we have a
separation of powers we have the
legislative power we have the judiciary
and we have the executives
now just like in the united states and
almost everywhere else in the world this
separation of power has been almost
almost destroyed because at this point
uh we're not being run by our
governments but rather by the executives
by uh the by the local governors for
example uh but it's not the lawmakers
who we voted into office who are calling
the shots by making laws but it's rather
it's the executive that uh is calling
the shots by making all kinds of
regulations that as for example the uh i
think the michigan and the wisconsin
supreme court and a federal court in
pennsylvania has spelled out in very
in very uh explicit terms you you're not
an emperor you can have
um emergency orders for a couple of days
but no longer than that then the
legislator the legislature has to step
in you have to involve them same thing's
happening here and that's why we have
all these orders about
mandatory mask wearing and social
distancing etc etc
and uh and and that's why the judiciary
has to step in and finally it is
stepping in here in germany
first uh it first happened in our
neighboring country in austria their
constitutional court only yesterday
issued an order saying that very same
thing
you cannot have the executive
run a mock you have to
get back to getting the legislature
involved and have a general discussion
about what's going on you can't just
follow one single opinion that's out
there um yet there are other scientists
who may have a completely different
picture of this story yeah that's pretty
intense so so that led you to want to go
and pursue this even more in germany
okay so
i have a few questions for you
that are very basic questions but you
know maybe
for someone like you that's in your
world this is how i process it i'm
curious and how you process it so for me
we are in shambles around the world in
march april u.s shuts down travel from
china to come in then sports shutdown
then hotels are going to 25 percent then
if you're not a you know
a uh
what do they call it the business if
you're not a
essential business you have to shut down
people are working from home
and
the majority of us are kind of sitting
around saying maybe this is true let's
just follow orders this is what we're
supposed to do fauci knows what he's
doing this person knows what he's doing
let's follow it let's go
if i'm an attorney my interest is
how was this caused who started it who
needs to be held accountable to it and
in what way
because i think if that part is not done
what makes us believe this will not
happen the next time for example the
germans had to pay reparation to the
jewish community and they just ended up
paying their mate last payment i think
2008 or 2010 and that was a long time so
other countries are like i don't ever
want to do that because i don't want to
pay that much reparation so it was a you
know a way of being punished so you're
an attorney
you know
who how are we gonna hold the people
accountable who started this
forget about who's politicizing it we'll
get to that next but how are we gonna
held the people accountable that started
this whole thing that affected and
pretty much stopped the whole world
within 90 days after us finding out
about it in china
well those are the exact same questions
that i asked myself uh together with
wolfgang vodak
he too said we have to first
find out what is really going on we have
to know about the real facts not just uh
believe the narrative that uh the
government is telling us but we have to
take a much closer look and then he put
me in touch with another attorney a
woman attorney by the name of viviana
fisher
she's an economist and an attorney and
my wife and i plus our dogs flew back to
germany i got in touch with her
and
two more lawyers who i had known from my
work at transparency international which
is a anti-corruption ngo um
which i used to work with
and uh we got together and we decided
it doesn't look like the government is
going to take a closer look at what's
going on uh so we're going to just take
over and we're going to do what the
government's supposed to do so what
we're what we're doing basically with
this investigative corona investigative
committee is we were almost acting like
a moot court uh or it was just like it
was almost like a mock trial we decided
to ask four or three basic questions how
dangerous is the virus really
the second question how
uh how much can we trust the pcr test
the positive result results what does it
really mean and the third question which
is really a two-part question is how
much damage do these anti-corona
measures do both to the economy and to
the health and well-being of the of the
world's population now the latter is
very easily answered this is probably
the worst crisis that the world has ever
been in with so many people dying in my
view in our view after all of what we've
heard
from our expert witnesses completely in
vain people who didn't get an operation
surgical procedures that were postponed
therapeutic measures that were not done
my sister is a nurse she works at a
hospital in my hometown in bremen which
is a port city and she kept telling me
right or there's something wrong
this entire hospital is almost empty
there's no one here and we're still
waiting for all these covet patients but
there's no one coming finally she had to
covet patients they died one of them was
80 something and the other one was 45
but she was a
a crack addict so what we initially
thought would hit us like a wave because
of all the announcement of dresden and
in england uh
what we thought would be a real pandemic
turned out to be
the common flu or if it is something
different it's no more lethal than the
common flu but back then when we started
our work on july 10th
we didn't know that we just had
questions we wanted to know we wanted to
get answers to these questions now the
last question i just answered the first
question is also simply answered because
that's what the wh o just came down with
um
by uh explaining that they agree with yo
anita's
assessment that this is no worse than
the common flu added mortality rate of
0.14 so the most important question was
what is it with these pcr tests because
if there's no real danger what are these
pcr tests telling us
because the government kept telling us
it tells you how many people are
infected with whatever
so that's what we constantly what we
then decided to concentrate on we asked
a bunch of scientists professor camera
of the universe she's an immunologist at
the university of wurzburg here in
germany professor cappell who's uh from
the netherlands another immunologist and
there's dr arve from
austria a microbiologist another
immunologist was dolores cahill she's
great from ireland and each and every
one told us
this pcr test is incapable of telling us
anything about infections
then i looked up this is all this came
out a couple of weeks ago then i read an
article by uh someone who is a real
heavyweight in the pharmaceutical
industry the former
vice president of pfizer
he was i think uh for 16 years he was
vice president and he was also a the
chief scientist and i read up what he
told us about the pcr test before i did
that i looked at all the videos i could
find of carrie mullis kerry mullis is
the inventor of the pcr test he got a
nobel prize for it he died unfortunately
last late last year
and he um in
on numerous occasions told everybody
that his pci test is a great test but it
is not good for detecting any infections
and an additional problem with this pcr
test is
that um
what what happens is with these swabs
you take molecules of
fragments
of molecules from the body which are
totally completely invisible to the
human eye so in order to make them
visible you have to kind of blow them up
amplify them is what they call this
put them into a machine then they're
amplified until finally they become
visible
at how many cycles
whatever becomes visible is very
important because this is the general
agreement right now across the world
including uh scientists who
write articles in the new york times
which is another one of the mainstream
media they all agree that anything above
35 cycles makes no scientific sense
anymore
a german leading german public uh health
agency in frankfurt they're saying we
discard we disregard anything over 25
cycles because we realize that it tells
us a lot of things but nothing about
infections with this virus
now these tests the ones that were
talking about the drugstone test was set
at 45 cycles so it was
this is what we believe now it was
deliberately set to produce as many
positive results as possible now uh dr
yaiden of uh former uh pfizer uh he says
these tests are completely useless uh he
says this test is fatally flawed and
must
for capital letters immediately be
withdrawn and never used again in this
setting unless shown to be fixed and his
article ends with the following
i have explained how a hopelessly
performing diagnostic test has been and
continues to be used not for diagnosis
of disease but it seems solely to create
fear and that's what this is all about
that's what this is all about it's about
creating fear so that people will not
ask any questions but do as they're told
i know this because there was a paper
that was leaked um by someone in the uh
german at the
office of the german secretary of the
interior this paper is now called the
panic paper and it includes explicit
uh explicit directions uh for the
government of how to how to
create panic one of the things that is
stated in there is
make children feel responsible for the
and this is the direct quote for the
torture deaths of their parents and
grandparents if they don't adhere to the
uh social distancing rules the mask
wearing rules uh
all these all these uh anti-corona
regulations so that's when i decided
when we learned this i decided this is
absolutely completely wrong this is not
about a corona pandemic this is a this
is a pcr test pandemic but for what
reason
um well this is something that i'm
saying this because i can prove this in
court because all the people who we
listen to in our corona committee will
say will definitely state the same
things as expert witnesses in the court
of law so we can prove that that the
virus is no no more dangerous than the
common flu and we can prove that the
assertion that pcr tests can detect
infections with the coronavirus is
definitely completely wrong
i forgot to mention that um
mike yaden dr
says that at least 94
of the positive results are false
positives if not more
okay and and i've seen a lot of things
obviously you said a lot of interesting
things here about the panic paper is the
panic paper public paper or it's a
private paper that we cannot see
oh i can send it to you it's in germany
yeah i'd love to see it
if you could and if you can email it
i'll have somebody translate it because
i'd love to see the the panic paper uh
you know for me i read all this stuff
and i said okay
i go online i listen to you give your
talk the talk that went viral and
everybody was you know it's been
translated in so many different
languages spanish it's all these
different languages the 45-minute speech
that you gave reading on what's going on
you started off in german then you went
in english then it's been translated
different languages
then i go around i think to myself and i
say okay i'm gonna be the skeptic here
okay
the world cannot all be on the same page
about this virus okay there's no way in
the world everybody's on the same page
why would they i mean i understand all
the issues we're facing in the world
especially last year year before maduro
venezuela 5g brexit
you know sanctions on china sanctions on
iran the middle east challenges that was
going on the elections in the u.s we got
a lot of things going on right now in
the world a lot at the same time it's
not like it's
you know going away it's all happening
in the same year okay so could somebody
politicize us and manipulate this great
for the populace around the world to
feel free
i have to feel free to know that there
are people who are willing to come
together to question all of this and go
to a court and win
so i know
these powerful people cannot bully the
rest of us that don't have access to all
this information
on a day-to-day basis how come that
hasn't happened yet how come more people
haven't come together to want to do
something about this yet how come
everything's still going on on a
day-to-day basis it's now been accepted
and everyone's just following whatever
orders their governors or their state
officials or the president's giving and
we're not seeing a pushback
from lawyers or anyone else going up
against them why haven't we seen that
yet
it is starting only now because only now
do people begin to understand here in
germany and in the rest of europe
probably in the united states as well
that this is not something that's going
to be over within a very short period of
time uh it's not like uh you can say oh
well maybe another month or so because
the uh the people who are behind this
the people who are trying to make as
much money
out of this as possible and who are
trying to and that's much more important
exert control over us uh will not let
let up so fast so the judiciary is the
last anchor so to speak of democracy if
global corporations
believe that they're above the law just
like i explained in in in the context of
deutsche bank and vw
uh if they believe they're above the law
and if they then decide that
they're going to lobby politicians in a
very massive way i'm going to explain
this to you in a second then all of a
sudden you have global corporations
overreaching doing things that really
shouldn't be in their power because you
have to remember
uh the who the world economic forum the
uh
united nations they're all private
supranational private organizations the
world economic forum for example was
invented by a german by the name of
klaus schwab he's a private person
this is an extremely powerful
organization right now because they
lobbied politicians through their annual
meetings at davos you may have heard of
this uh that's where they mingle and
that's where many politicians who may
not be the
toughest people in the world but who
constantly have to pretend that they're
in power and that they know what they're
doing where many many politicians are
really flattered by being so close to
the really powerful so you have the
self-appointed political elite and you
have the self-appointed um corporate
elites who are meeting over and over
again
and the the they're they're much too
close they're so close that in the
meantime they have in some instances
usurped the government's powers
sovereign powers for example the most
important right that we have all over
the world is the right to free speech
it's the fundamental right it's the most
important right for a democracy because
you have to be able to discuss different
opinions which is not happening right
now and the power to regulate this
should be the government's power but
look at what's happening my english
version of my video was taken down by
youtube that's google so they believe
that they have the power to censor us
that is not right we have to take back
the powers from them and put them back
to where it belongs to the government
and we have to take a really close look
at who is in government and who became
too close to these corporations
but that's basically what's been
happening and i was going to tell you uh
the concrete um
instance of how we
became alerted to this
one of us
happened to be watch a video clip on the
internet it was filmed in may of 2019
and this was a congress that was held by
the
leading german governmental party uh cdu
which is short for christian democratic
union
uh we have a uh grant what is called a
grand coalition which is ruling our
country and the stronger one of the two
parties is the she is the cdu they help
this congress in may of 2019
may of 2019. now you would expect all of
the people will play a role in this
party to be there angela merkel was
there the secretary of health his name
is jens spahn he was there but in
addition to that there was this now
infamous professor
dr uh christian dresden
of charity university the one who pushed
the idea that this is going to be a
really dangerous pandemic and the one
who convinced the world not just germany
but the world because his test was
recommended by the world health
organization to be used all over the
world he convinced the world that with
pcr tests you can see how many people
are infected with the corona virus with
covet
um so he was there and at first i
thought well maybe he's a member of the
cdu no uh there's more there was
professor wheeler he runs the german
equivalent of the cdc's the rki
professor wheeler who's a veterinarian
how did he get into that position then
there was tedras of uh
of the world health organization dr
tedras many people think he's the doctor
no he's a philosopher and there were the
uh there were the the two leading um
lobbyists of the two biggest most
important richest um
uh healthcare organizations in the world
which is on the one hand the bill and
melinda gates foundation and on the
other hand the welcome trust they were
all there now this could have been a
coincidence but we kept looking and then
we could see that these people had met
over and over and over again through the
years and these very same people who met
in may of 2019 19
they're the ones who then called the
pandemic in march of 2020 the very same
people and it was dresden whose paper
which is a very uh
he wrote a paper in uh in january
january 23rd i think it was published
and the expert who we spoke with say
it's really sloppy he wrote it with
other authors it's very sloppy uh but
it's the one it's the it's the most
important it's a centerpiece of this i
was going to say campaign of this
pandemic because it spells out that with
pc with a pcr test that he invented
specifically for this purpose we would
be able to tell uh how many who is
infected and how many people are
infected a blatant lie as we now know
um at the same time this is another
thing we found this out a week ago there
was a chinese paper which was also
written about this pandemic and how to
best fight it
the chinese paper was very well done and
one of the professors who advises us on
our committee said the chinese don't
need any advice from the germans they
don't need any help from us they could
have taken the chinese paper and now it
turns out the drastic paper was only
there to convince the rest of the world
to use the pcr tests in order to test
for infections the chinese paper
seems to be the one that was used by the
chinese now the chinese don't have a
pandemic anymore they understood very
quickly that this is made up maybe they
took part in making this object
okay so
i'm a mother my job is to make sure my
kids are healthy i take care of them i
maybe if i'm not married who should give
them shelter
feed them if i am married to do my part
as a mom if i got a job i'll go make
money as well but i have
responsibilities as a mom i'm a father i
have my own responsibilities i go do my
job whatever my job is i make my 50
grand a year 100 grand or 200 grand
whatever it is i got a house put my kids
to school all this stuff i don't want to
think about military because that's not
my job that's a soldier's job and the
general's job to make sure if we have an
attack we have the right weapons we are
fully trained we are ready that's not my
job i don't have that responsibility
it's somebody else's responsibility
today
the people are sitting around saying
it's not my responsibility to find out
who is responsible for this
you're saying the judiciary is the last
anchor of democracy right okay
so you're in germany who else is coming
together attorneys from different parts
to the world to want to go up and say
hey
all of you power people that did what
you did you got to be held accountable
to it now here's what we need
what what kind of power
is there to hold them accountable
specifically since you're saying
they're not going to slow down and
they're not going to stop they're going
to be pushing this until they get what
they want what kind of power do you
and lawyers around the world have to
push them around and hold them
accountable
well uh we have the power of using
asking the courts of law to step in but
we have to show in a court of law that
this is not a corona pandemic but rather
a staged pcr test pandemic which was uh
which was made up and invented for
completely different purposes for
gaining for these corporations we can't
we do not know exactly who's responsible
we we see that some of the corporations
that are now censoring us are in part
responsible we know some of the people
who are investing their money like bill
gates or this uh klaus schwab or
blackrock who are investing their money
into pharmaceutical in uh in technical
companies and also in the mainstream
media so that they're gonna be brought
into line and they're not gonna report
about the other side of the story
and uh in order to bring out this story
we have to have a court of law
that uh will take a look at the evidence
that is there not just at this one point
of view but at all the other evidence
that is there and that's what we're
doing right now we're doing this both in
germany and in the united states i'm i
i'm going to tell you who it is but not
right now because i have to get i have
to get there okay first because i don't
want to
um i don't want to disturb the really
really really good relation working
relationship and friendly relationship
that we have right now the united states
and canada are so important in this
because they're the two countries i
think there's a third country i think
australia but i know my way around in us
law so the united states and canada are
very important for this because they're
the two countries that have class
actions class actions mean if you have a
law if you have somebody who goes to a
court of law because they feel that
they've been uh defrauded by deutsche
bank or uh or vw
uh or by the makers of these pcr tests
by dresden who uh uh told the entire
world that this pcr test is good for
testing uh
people are whether they're uh
infectious
if someone
who suffered damages because of the pcr
test induced lockdowns decides to go to
court in order to ask the court
give me
please
uh hold this guy or this corporation
accountable and if this someone then
decides to tell the judge listen i'm not
the only one there's a couple hundred
more there's a couple of thousand more
there's hundreds of thousands of more
people who suffered the same kind of
damages because their businesses were
also shut down they didn't make any
money um during the months of uh what uh
march through june
um
he may then ask the uh a judge to decide
to allow this
to be a class action if the judge then
allows this a window opens a a time
window of i don't know six months seven
months or so and uh this is going to be
published wherever uh other people who
suffered the same kind of damage are in
this case that could be worldwide
because the entire world suffered the
same kind of damage because everybody
kind of followed suit after dresden and
world health organization tried to tell
the rest of the world and and
successfully did so
that these pcr tests tell you about
infections and because of all the
infections we have to have lockdowns
and uh what's happening right now is
we're preparing a lot a couple of
lawsuits in the united states and in
canada
um
this has to be done very well because
this is it's important not to make fools
of ourselves and it's important to do
the best we can for our clients we're
doing the same thing in germany uh and
in the rest of the world um but in
germany we don't have class actions and
in the rest of the world we don't either
but what we have in germany because of
our corona investigative committee is
much of the evidence so all of our
colleagues who call us or write us i
can't speak with everyone because
there's so many of them or send us
emails to the corona committee um or to
me my law office uh we advise them that
here
you
on this website you'll find everything
you need
and we're trying to do our best and it's
really hard because it's extremely it's
it's extremely hard work but we're
trying to do out our best to educate as
many of our colleagues in nepal in uh
ghana and all these countries as to what
the facts really are so that they then
with the use of these facts based on
these facts because the facts are more
important than the law uh based on these
facts they can bring their own cases in
their own country or in germany because
that's where the main perpetrator is
were uh what i would now call the main
war criminal is that's justin and
wheeler
my uh my question for you now would be
you know while you're saying this is
okay
so are there any other cases in the past
where a country has been irresponsible
on releasing a virus i know you're going
a different direction you're going
through the pc you know the the the
method of the doctor who even came up
with it who died end of last year the
pcr test and he said it's not accurate
100 you can't just rely on this but you
watch all his videos you're going that
direction but the release of the virus
if it started in wuhan and it started
with china are there any other cases to
make comparables to on how
a country like china was held
accountable to make sure they don't do
that again
i really am not aware of this but i am
aware of the rumors and uh there is some
substance to these rumors i think but
uh of uh china or someone else um
kind of releasing this virus of
artificially creating this virus but i
don't have enough oh that's not my
question the question isn't that this is
my question let me let me clarify my
question so it makes sense i'm not i'm
not saying well uh uh
you know we know it came out of wuhan
lab you know we know we know that part
that's not something that's not been uh
validated the world knows it came from
china what i'm asking you is
that
in the past are there any other cases
where a country
a handling of a virus by a country was
so irresponsible that it affected
neighboring countries
that the world tribunal tribunal held
them accountable
where
all the other countries are like listen
we cannot make a mistake like that again
or else we're going to be held
accountable at this level it's going to
cost us this much money is there any
other case to go to to say here's what
happened to xyz country in 1948 is there
anything like that
i don't think so i'm not aware of any
yeah because i think that that's that's
my concern my concern is
uh if we ever wanted to find out and
you know uh test out
uh uh how to
confuse and scare the hell out of the
world within six weeks
in a bio warfare attack to shut down the
entire world
we just got a perfect uh
you know case study on how to do the
last nine months
well it's uh
robert kennedy and i appeared at uh one
of the the largest demonstration that
was ever held in germany that was on
august the 29th in berlin and he uh
reminded people of
he quoted franklin d roosevelt by saying
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
and that's what this is all about fear
is being created by way of using these
pcr tests and fear is being created in
order to make people do what they're
told without asking any questions
yeah for me i just want accountability
my interest is accountability i just
want to make sure the right people are
held accountable so you know in the end
you know in the end it's going to be the
governments who are going to be held
accountable that's great
yeah and that's why we're but we're the
we're targeting those people who are out
there in the open who make the mistakes
who well they didn't make innocent
mistakes but who lied to us who gave us
false statements of fact because they're
the ones that the governments relied on
so
if we hit them and if we can prove and
i'm sure we can if we can show in a
court of law that they lied to the
people and this particular person
professor dressed in light in many many
more ways to the people because he's
neither a professor nor did he ever
write a dissertation it's a fake that's
another thing that came out last week
but if we can show that the government
in our case angela merkel relied on one
person only and that person is a fraud
in many respects then this government
loses all credibility and it'll be
easier for a new government to come in
and hopefully come to a political
solution so we don't have to wait until
the end of the case that we have in a
court of law but in once the whole thing
gets started and once the evidence is
being uh once the
witnesses are being heard in a court of
law it will become very quickly very
clear
that this is one big i hate to use this
word but one big hoax
so
you know that's the word that you use
that the the algorithms don't like but
so yeah i understand uh many people have
said that as well you're not the only
person that said it but you seem like a
stubborn man who is not going to stop
until
you figure out what you want to do
because
going up against deutsche bank and
volkswagen was almost a training ground
for you to go up against this one
because this is bigger than those two
you went up against but you did say at
the beginning truth will prevail
what is your plan now the four of you
what are you guys doing as you're going
right now and what's going to stop you
guys until you get by you get to the
bottom of this
well we're um we're going to continue
with our work because more and more
evidence comes out in the meantime at
first we concentrated on who is directly
responsible those are the three people
uh dresden wheeler and tedros and of
course the organizations behind them the
who is one of the responsible
organizations but then it turns out that
of course they're the ones who are out
there in the open but there's somebody
else there who's behind them and pulling
the strings we can see them
uh through the fog we can see them ever
clear but we do believe that with the
help of the anglo-american legal system
including the law of evidence which is
much more advanced than any other
country's law of evidence including
pre-trial discovery we believe that the
facts are going to take us right there
to the people who are actually
responsible not just to the puppets the
marionettes but to the people who are
really pulling the strings do you have
any idea who those are or not yet
well we know that some of the people who
invested their money uh are the the same
ones who invested their money in these
corporations plus the media one of them
is bill gates um but there's others uh
who like um huge corporations or or
funds like a blackrock for example
they're
all those players that come to mind may
have something to do with this however
there's no reason to be afraid
again uh there's
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
because there's not a kind of monolithic
antagonist on the other side but there's
different interests that are competing
with each other and there's some people
on the other side who don't seem to be
knowing
don't don't seem to know what they're
doing because as we found out last week
when we took a closer look at uh
professor druzden's dissertation it
turns out it doesn't exist it was made
up only this year when people tried to
dig deeper if we don't lose our nerves
but concentrate focus on what we're
supposed to do go after the people who
we can see for what they did lying or uh
telling people uh giving people false
statements of fact about the pcr test
that's going to lead us to where we
really want to go and it's going to give
us i think
a quick solution once the people once
the politicians who relied on these
experts come under pressure because
their experts are
really the emperors without clothes if
you take a closer look yeah i mean it's
very interesting you know it for the
people that are watching right now what
will be your final thoughts before we
wrap up this interview
on
you know the average person watching
this is not a lawyer the average person
watching this hasn't gone against
deutsche bank the average person
watching this doesn't wake up every
morning wanting to find out more
evidence that's your job that's what you
do on a daily basis what should the
average person who's watching this who
runs a business is trying to do whatever
they can to keep their employees
employed so they can go pay you know for
their rent their daily things that they
need to be doing what are the final
thoughts you have for them before we
wrap up this interview
well um it it's uh
it's two things basically uh do not give
up and keep asking questions because the
more people
are asking questions the more answers we
will get both in a court of law but
eventually also from politicians and as
i said i don't think it's going to take
us a year or two
to go all the way through with these
lawsuits once they start and once the
hearings begin once the experts are
being heard in a court of law this is
going to spread the word and people will
begin to understand that not only do
they have a claim for damages but also
do we have a means to make sure that
this will not never happen again by for
example asking the courts of law to uh
give us punitive damages that's another
very strong weapon in the anglo-american
legal system that we don't have in the
german system for example
it's going to be very interesting what
happens right after election if right
after election states like california
new york all of a sudden open up you
knew this you know this was politicized
uh and if right after election they
still keep playing the games of what's
going on here then maybe it's a vaccine
game i don't know
we're gonna learn a lot in the next four
or five days on how everybody else
reacts to the election whether trump
gets elected whether biden gets elected
or whether we have to wait a week two
three weeks for all the other votes to
come in to find out who's gonna end up
being a president but i do know the next
five days are going to be very very
weird days as we're going into this
election how can people find you by the
way is there a website people can go to
find you
yeah if you want to address me directly
i'd rather you uh address the corona
committee but if you want to address me
directly it's fullmage.com that's my
website
we're going to put that link below and
how do they address the corona committee
directly how did they do that what's the
website there
um we're trying to have an english
version of it but right now there's only
the german version you do get english
answers though the german version is
corona
that's the german word for committee
that's spelled a-u-s-s-c-h-u-s-s
dot d-e
we're gonna put both of those links
below for people to go follow and if
they got any questions they will reach
out to you doctor thank you so much for
making the time for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you very much for having me it was
a pleasure so what you think about the
story what do you think about his
testimony do you believe him are you on
his side do you disagree do you think
what the media is saying is true do you
think what all these powerful political
people are saying is true or do you
think there's something going on behind
closed doors i don't know comment below
your thoughts and you may want to share
this video because i don't quite frankly
know whether it will stay up or not i
have no
reason to believe it won't or it will
but you may want to share with others so
they get a chance to see it for
themselves as well and if you watch this
interview you liked it there's another
one i want you to watch with robert
kennedy jr i did which we went really
deep and click over here to watch that
interview if you're not subscribed to
the channel please do so as well take
care everybody bye